hey there everyone john trigonis here
author of crowdfunding for filmmakers
second edition and IndieGoGo is campaign
strategist for film and creative
campaigns I'm going to pet you by the
end of the night and I am here today to
talk to you about the six biggest
mistakes that crowdfunding content
creators filmmakers videographers always
tend to make because I don't want you
making these mistakes I want you to be
as successful as possible so we're gonna
start I'm gonna jump right in
number six not really sure if these are
actually numbered but these are pretty
big I did kind of number them you know
from like least two the biggest who's
your day so wait until later you're
gonna see some crazy stuff
number six biggest mistake here is a
heavy reliance on press and PR to get
your campaign outside of your general
Network the idea is we've got a campaign
I'm gonna post it and post it but that's
gonna get me to a certain level so what
we're gonna need to do is o get some
press and maybe get some influencers on
board and that works sometimes it works
when you put in the work to build
yourself into those communities and get
to know those influencers get to know
the publications that are gonna put your
stuff out there because if you don't
you're just another crowdfunding
filmmaker trying to make a film and
there are dozens of us out there how's
the smile the smile magnetic don't
really smile like this but I know the
cameras on you know
I'm just making it up as I'm going along
so that said if you do want to get those
influencers attention get on their radar
and do them this favor offer them value
don't ask them to write about your
campaign write about your film write
about film in general that somehow
relates to your campaign later and pitch
it to them because their audience is
probably gonna want to read that article
and then by reading that article written
by you you just happen to be
crowdfunding they're gonna be more
willing to take an active interest in
that campaign so that is number six
number five boring what I call standard
definition perks or incentives number
one rule of any kind of filmmaking is
don't be boring right you know comics
like before like you know Stephen
Colbert comes out on the stage he's got
a dude to come out and like do stupid
he's a comic that you've never
heard of and he tells you laughs laughs
do this and then he leaves and then all
of a sudden Colbert's out you're all
warmed up and you're ready to like be a
part of the show so the same rule
applies and crowdfunding the perks are
almost the lifeblood of what makes
people contribute to an actual campaign
so you know what give them some perks
give them some cool interesting perks
I've made it easy for you in my book
I've broken it down into three types
standard definition you do need those
and I'll tell you what those are in a
second high definition perks and
three-dimensional perks so standard
definition we've got mandatory items
high definition our experiences and 3d
perks are personalized experiences that
you can't get anywhere else
becoming one with the actual film so
standard definition you're gonna have
your movie you're making a movie I need
to see the movie if you expect me to
back the project so I need to see it
first high definition perks
give me an experience at one point the
executive and associate producer credit
was okay
now those are kind of falling under the
standard definition realm because as
crowdfunding of Olives this is a normal
everyday thing to offer what is an
experience getting me on set giving me a
speaking role heck let me write some of
the lines for your film the more access
you can give to your Kintla to your
backers the more they're gonna want to
be a part of your campaign and make you
more successful than you can imagine at
crowdfunding but you gotta put in again
the work you got to think about those
perks you got to think about your
audience you got to give them what they
want and they do want cool things if you
have to write 50 poems I wrote a hundred
of them fifties nothing but if you've
got to write fifty poems at $10 a piece
well guess what that's the work that's
what you got to do and if you use that
as an entry level 3d personalized perk
to get them to maybe go to twenty-five
or fifty and get the DVD or get the
other experiential perks you know what
they're gonna go because they're still
gonna get that very personal thing so
don't be boring with those incentives
and don't be cheap on it don't skimp on
these ones biggest mistakes man the next
one number four is interesting not soft
launching your campaign so soft
launching what does that mean
basically means you're going to should I
cut okay cool well we could fade that
hey think I'm taking a I'm hearing
like so number four biggest mistake not
soft launching your crowdfunding
campaign now question might be what's a
soft launch the soft launch is the
launch that happens before the official
launch before the first tweet goes out
before the first email gets sent and
before the first facebook post gets
posted right and this is so important
because the fact is this your friends
and your family are going to be the
first people to contribute whether you
want to believe that or not it is
absolute truth so you're gonna have to
number one be comfortable asking your
friends and your family to not
contribute money to the campaign
but to actually be a part of your film
in your campaign and yes that just so
happens to mean they're gonna have to
give some money but we need them first
because here's the thing about it
crowdfunding is physics and crowdfunding
is psychology the physics is momentum
and we need that momentum at the
beginning of the campaign so you
soft-launched to them only and say hi
mom hi dad
I love you you're awesome you've
supported me I need your support again
with a contribution to my film because I
want to make it awesome and I need it
now
and you should be able here's the Crick
the crazy thing you should be able to
get 30% of those funds in the first
let's say three days so whatever amount
you want to set 30% got to come from
friends family and if you're lucky to
have them fans and it's got to happen in
the first three days to secure the
momentum because then the this kayak and
tripped over those words too many
science is there in the first three days
because then the physics part is over
you've built the momentum next comes the
psychology when I stumble on your
campaign as a person who doesn't even
know who you are and I check out your
campaign before I look at your video
before I look at the perks the first
thing I'm gonna look at is to see how
well you're doing I'm gonna look to that
green bar that tells me whether or not
you're successful yet or you're getting
close or you're not even close
and the more close you are to getting
30% or more the more psychologically I
think to myself this person's a winning
horse of a campaign and I'm gonna put my
money on that horse actually we have
this cool it's actually one of the
cooler tech products on IndieGoGo it's a
cat litter box that is three levels so
what happens is you stack them in threes
you fill it up and you put the cat
litter on the top and then the cat shits
in it and then all you do you lift the
first level you shake it out the sand
goes through the slits and the
stays there next up man this is a tough
one no strategy huge mistake I mean
think about it
crowdfunding right everybody gets
excited it's free money it's not free
money
you're gonna work for that money you're
gonna work hard for it and the more
money you want the more strategy you've
got to have and what do I mean by
strategy is tragedy but what do I mean
by strategy is tragedy
I mean setting daily goals knowing that
on day six you're gonna launch a new
perk knowing that on day 10 you're gonna
have an update video that thanks every
person name by name by name just because
you're feeling generous and then you
know impress is gonna come out tell us
when that press comes out send another
update blast it out to the email
following post it all over social media
launch another new perk this is all part
of the strategy and if you have to do
crazy stunts awesome plan them out in a
in advance and figure out where in the
lifeline of your campaign they should be
because the campaign itself shouldn't be
boring either it should be an experience
from the first days which if you soft
launch that campaign like we talked
about a second ago launch the campaign
you're gonna have a strong launch and
people are gonna be excited but even the
strongest soft launch it dies down gets
smaller as it goes unless you strategize
what we call the lull the lull is that
quiet time that scares everybody
sometimes people call it the trough of
despair because they just don't think
they're gonna get out of okay it's so
scary
no strategize it plan ahead to know when
you're gonna do this and then by the end
of the campaign there's gonna be a spike
but you can control that spike do some
kind of a live event have a good time
with this campaign and always think what
is gonna keep my audience engaged no
different than when you're writing and
shooting a film with dance dance for me
okay sorry channeling my inner Pesci
how's it focus out next up this is
number two now we're getting pretty
crazy I haven't even had drink yet proud
and I thought number two and number one
are interesting because normally I say
number two is number one
and then number one is number two and I
switch them every couple of days but for
this one I'm saying number two biggest
mistake setting too high a goal I'm
gonna say it again because it's that
important setting too high a goal now if
you know anything about me you know that
one thing is certain I believe in what
my good friend Adam chap Nick once said
that if you're crowdfunding for the
money you are absolutely doing it wrong
straight up so that said the funding
should not be the most important thing
you may need a hundred thousand dollars
for this film you may see dozens of
other campaigns raising $100,000 or more
sometimes that doesn't necessarily mean
we can raise a hundred thousand dollars
it's not easy
twenty thousand in 2016 is still very
hard to raise so the one advice I always
give to counterbalance this whole
biggest mistake thing is to check
yourself look in the mirror and then
look at your social media fix your hair
in the mirror of course and then look at
your social media and say to yourself
how many fans do I have on my Facebook
page how many followers do I have on
Twitter how many connections do I have
on LinkedIn how many people do I email
on a regular basis
look at all of those factors and then
look at your goal and ask yourself can
my family and friends and fans if you're
lucky to have them
can they get me 30% of that X dollar
amount that I'm looking for and if the
answer is no it's totally great then ask
yourself how much can they get me and
then multiply that by three set that as
your goal knowing that the rest of that
70% of that funding goal is going to
come from mostly your social media
network and your email connections and
then if you do all of that you'll be
able to ascend to get more to get wider
reach out into the world because you've
proven that can
pain and more campaigns that hit a let's
say a lower goal but a goal they can
work with will always go above that goal
always go above it
sometimes by about 30% so it's always in
your best interest to set a goal that
you aren't sure that you can hit the
other part of it is pretty simple you
know when you look at it that way it's
like you want to have a success under
your belt the world we live in
yes we measure success by whether or not
you hit the funding goal in crowdfunding
that's not how I measure success that's
not how we should measure success but it
is so we got a cater to that idea that
psychology that is in play and make sure
people can just see your campaign and be
like wow this person is totally going to
hit this goal and it's a great project
and that person's awesome I'm in and
they're gonna go all in number one we
are at number one it is nuts not having
an audience is the number one biggest
crowdfunding mistake now I know what you
might be thinking you might be thinking
trick crowdfunding isn't about the money
you just said that so it must be about
the community in the audience building
so I'm gonna build an audience while I'm
crowdfunding you're absolutely right you
are but you should start now if you want
a crowdfunding six months from now you
should be tweeting you should be
Facebook posting you should be
instagramming every day on sets just
your life if you have a cat take a
picture you cat spice it up a little bit
you know take a picture of the food it's
a big thing and then take a picture of
the set and take five more pictures of
the set and when you read something on
Twitter share it
send the retweet out hashtag a few
things tell us what you liked about that
article that we should probably like
about that article give value to your
audience every single day it doesn't
matter if it's an audience of 5 or 500
because if you do that for a month for
two months you're gonna then have an
audience of 500 or 5,000 and the bigger
your network is the more potential you
have to raise larger sums of money not
necessarily because it's
come from Twitter and Facebook but
because you're gonna have that wider
reach for people if they can't
contribute on Twitter but they see your
link they may give you the retweet
because you've retweeted great content
to them and they're gonna send it to
their friends and one of those people
one of those people might be the person
that gives you $500 as a contribution
and it's happened to me it happens to a
lot of people but you have to put in the
work and I'm gonna give you a bonus one
biggest mistake simply not doing the
work and the work is every single thing
I said there because I tried to have it
you know this video is about the biggest
mistakes I don't like to focus on the
mistakes because the mistakes when
they're made they're done but we have to
learn from them and I want to teach you
what you should know so look at those
big mistakes that's great we've got
those big mistakes covered and we've got
those things to teach us how to be how
to do it right right and the biggest
thing is we have to be willing to put in
that work and if you're willing to put
in the work and connect individually
with your friends followers family
everybody you know your crowdfunding
campaign for that film is going to be
super successful and you're gonna be
writing blogs and the next thing you
know I'm gonna have competition because
you're gonna write the next crowd
funding for filmmakers and on that note
I hope that helped you were better when
you're taking a